just about every state and local
government is in a financial bind
because they're spending more than they
take in public sector pensions are a
major factor here
they already represent a big part of
spending and they're underfunded by
somewhere between one and five trillion
dollars as those shortfalls come do
either taxpayers are going to get
screwed through higher taxes and reduce
services where public sector retirees
are going to take a hell of a haircut
here are three reasons to fix public
sector pensions now
unsustainable pension payouts played a
large role at municipal bankruptcies in
places such as Detroit and Vallejo
California in the 250 largest cities in
the country pensions on average soak up
10% of budgets a 30 percent increase
over just the past five years as
retirees start outnumbering workers and
the new york police department already
has more former cops drawing a pension
than active ones walking a beat the
amount of money spent on pensions is
only get a skyrocket
public employees typically get to retire
earlier and they pay less into their
retirements than their counterparts in
the private sector on top of that many
workers gain the system through often
legal tricks such as spiking which is
the act of artificially boosting the
salary level upon which the retirement
payments are calculated for instance by
cashing in unused sick days of vacation
Phoenix Arizona's former city manager
was able to jack up his annual
retirement pay by almost $90,000 to a
whopping two hundred thirty four
thousand five hundred and thirty six
dollars
most government pensions guaranteed
payouts based on unrealistic investment
returns California said the investments
in its pension funds would return 8%
every year while the actual returns have
been far lower the results is that
California's pension fund are only about
42 percent funded taxpayers ultimately
pick up the difference as more public
sector workers retire pensions are only
going to become a bigger and bigger
issue it's time to reform public sector
pensions by reining in lavish promises
closing loopholes and switching over to
pay-as-you-go 401k style plans that most
private sector workers have for reason
TV I'm Nicholas